i honestly think that that it's that's
not how it works
my point being is like you guys uh
either read or seen clockwork orange
right i just read the book okay i just
finished
so yesterday the whole point of the the
movie and the book
was was this one idea and i think so
many people
kind of see it as something else and and
for what i saw it was
was that they're they take this kid who
is admittedly
very ultraviolet you know he's a
sociopath
and then they take a government protocol
where they they try to
hammer in ethical and moral ideas well
they deal with
science right with what they look at as
a a system they give a system
and then they force them to watch they
give them a drug they shoot them up with
a drug the book is fantastic but the
movie's a
masterpiece what they did with language
is probably second master
anthony purchased but they they shut him
up so they take they take him he's a
young
he's a droogie and he uh has his
three drugs uh dim peter and georgie
and his name is alex and they're from
there he's got this
manchester accent and they go about and
they
rape and they kill and they maim
and his favorite thing for entertainment
the old ultra violence he calls it
where they and there are rape scenes in
that movie that movie's so shocking and
and
is he doing that stuff went before they
give him the drugs so yeah so he's a bad
bad
he's a young okay he's a young druggie
and he gets off on violence he's
so clearly a sociopath a sadistic
sociopath he gets off on destroying
human beings which he talks about
he gets arrested for killing an old
woman
he then is put into the system
and two years into his prison sentence
they say we have a cure
well this sounds like charleston a
criminal story so they have him strapped
to a chair and they shoot him up with it
with a
medicine they prop his eyes open in the
movie they have his eyes open like that
remember that scene and they force him
to watch violent movies
and he starts to get sick when he used
to be turned on he gets
sick he starts to throw up and so
violence rape all these things now even
the thought of it make him
wretch so this the the government has
cured him
but with the the theme of the book and
the theme of the movie is now you've
taken away choice
you've taken away moral choice you've
just made it
impossible for him to do good bad things
because you'll get sick but you haven't
you haven't changed the guy
you haven't changed and the argument the
argument is and of course
in the end and in the end it doesn't
really yeah in the end it doesn't really
work
in the end and in the book in the book
he actually gets all he just grows up
and he goes you know i'm good destroying
isn't as good as creating and he just
gets older
but in in the movie there's a scene in
prison and i thought this was one of the
best little
pieces of spice that kubrick put on it
there's a scene where he's in the
library after this treatment
spoiler and he's dude the movie came out
50 [ __ ] years ago
one of the greatest movies [ __ ] you you
got a spoiler it's a
it's a mind blower um it's a [ __ ]
mind blowing
there's a scene where where alex alex
has has gone through this program and
then as brian put it he's physically
been changed but um he's he's you know
now living a life he's into studies and
he's wearing the uniform the whole thing
and he's in the school library and a
priest comes up to him and he says alex
how's it
how's it going and he says oh i'm right
my right
is rain sir and you get all the good and
uh the priest says okay i just want you
to know he's like
he's he said he brings me he said
goodness comes from within
goodness has to come from within it's
not something that can be applied to you
it's a choice and and
that's my big concern about all of this
too especially in the in this world
where we have like white fragility
and this idea these ideas these ethical
um
moral commandments that are being pushed
on people children and adults
it's not enough to be a racist now you
have to be anti-racist you can't be
you can't be a non-racist now you have
to be anti-racist so silence is racist
right well white silence is violence you
hear this stuff too
so these are the things i object to well
that and my point is is that
i had the incredible luxury of growing
up in
one of i honestly i'll take the pepsi
challenge with anyone i grew up in one
of the most diverse
places on the [ __ ] planet a a white
anglo-saxon was by far
the minority in in where i grew up and
i arrived at a point where i really do
feel that i am as as as enlightened as i
can be to all separate
cultures and that wasn't because of any
book i read
it wasn't because of any any type of uh
adult figure or or or or figure of
authority trying to
impose these ideas on me it was because
i had to live amongst people and talk to
them
and made mistakes and [ __ ] up put my
foot in my mouth and it clearly offended
people
then learned and then felt better about
myself when i understood people
then got turned on by the idea of
opening my mind to [ __ ] different
walks of life oh [ __ ] and
and you can't you can't kind of
synthesize that
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing